introducing the cross fixed meniscal
repair system from Cayenne medical an
innovative approach to meniscal repair
featuring a suture only device that
creates an instantaneous mattress stitch
for fast strong and reliable all inside
meniscal repair
the procedure begins with assessing the
tare and determining its repair ability
after portal placement is determined the
probe is introduced to measure the
distance from the capsule to the
preferred entry point on the meniscus
this distance will be used for the depth
limiter configuration with the depth
limiter fully extended
the delivery needles are inserted into
the joint space and positioned for
repair based on the preferred meniscal
entry point of the device the depth
limiter is retracted to the desired
distance by moving the black lever to
the right and then down
the delivery needles are inserted into
the meniscus capturing the tear the
delivery needles will be in position
when the depth limiter pushes against
the municipal surface limiting
advancement with the delivery needles in
position the trigger is squeezed to
deploy the suture the trigger can be
released after hearing an audible click
when the trigger is released the
crossing needle retracts leaving the
suture behind the delivery needles are
removed from the knee and a sliding knot
advances into position
the post end of the suture is cut off of
the device the cut white end is the post
end and the curly black end is the
locking end the post end of the suture
is pulled advancing the sliding knot
which reduces the meniscal tear if the
initial reduction of the meniscal tear
is not satisfactory the cross fix knot
pusher suture cutter is used to further
reduce the tear first the white end of
the suture or post end is threaded
through the knot pusher suture cutter
the suture can be loaded by hand or with
the packaged snare the knot pusher
suture cutter slides down the suture on
to the knot gentle pressure on the knot
combined with firm tension applied to
the post end of the suture completely
reduces the meniscal tear once
satisfactory reduction is achieved the
black free end of the suture is pulled
to lock the knot into position half
hitches can be added at this point as
required in preparation for cutting the
suture both ends are threaded through
the cross fix knot pusher suture cutter
the knot pusher suture cutter slides
down the suture onto the knot the tip
rests against the not allowing for a two
to three millimeter tail
pulling the black trigger cuts the
suture
the cross fixed surgical technique
offers surgeons a complete solution for
meniscal tear repair the all inside
technique creates an instantaneous 3
millimeter mattress stitch with a single
insertion into the meniscus and pre-tied
sliding knot the suture only devised
reduces the risk of Kandra injury common
to implantable plastic devices the
technique is fast and easy
resulting in reliable and reproducible
outcomes the device provides
biomechanically strong fixation with
pullout forces equal to open suture
techniques straight and curved delivery
needles allow for easier access to
multiple tear sites